the 250 GTO is the most Tally's Matic of  the models it's really the holy grail of  all the collects motor cars out there  well they rarely come to market because  fundamentally they're just so rare  people who own a 250 GTO are reluctant  sellers they don't really want to sell a  car they're that good when one does come  to market they tend to get traded quite  quickly quite privately  it's a record-breaking car because it  was a car that was in period was  dominant it was unbeatable it's not a  trailer Queen it's not a car that's  going to necessarily win Concorde eligor  sees but it's in great road-going  condition then you look at it and you  see the aesthetics of the car and you've  pretty much got the Royal Flush there's  a pyramid of desirability and let's face  it for our is at the top of that pyramid  so they're a very hot interesting traded  commodity can be argued that these are  living masterpieces these motor cars  you